podría ser una nueva arma en la lucha
contra la pandemia global el anuncio de
facer que su vacuna funciona para
personas de entre 5 y 11 años podría
abrir la puerta a que más países
vacunarán a los más pequeños
si medimos la habilidad de los
anticuerpos de los niños que fueron
vacunados de combatir al virus y su
nivel de coincidencia con los
anticuerpos de los jóvenes de 16 a 25
años y tenían altos niveles de
coincidencia en metz pericos la gigante
farmacéutica estadounidense explicó que
a los niños solo les administró una
tercera parte de la dosis que se usan
normalmente pero que la respuesta
inmunitaria fue igual de efectiva
fighter asegura que someterá el uso a
las autoridades reguladoras para finales
de mes la compañía defiende que el uso
de su fármaco devolvería a los más
pequeños la posibilidad de una crianza
en condiciones normales me gustaría
recordar a la gente que esto va más allá
de los niños que se enferman y tienen el
potencial de transmitir el virus a las
personas vulnerables sino que hablamos
de la manera como esto ha interrumpido
la vida normal de los niños y de que
puedan tener una educación cara a un
aprendizaje en persona y desarrollar
actividades dentro y fuera de la escuela
kaiser hizo el anuncio a través de un
comunicado de prensa y todavía debe dar
los detalles en una publicación
científica ciertos científicos
calificaron la noticia de esperanzadora
pero insistieron en que quieren ver más
evidencias antes de que se lleve a la
práctica